[Music]
alright Gilmore Girls listen up the
highly anticipated Netflix revival is
officially out and we have some major
stars hollow seekers to discuss but if
you have not watched yet or do not want
to be spoiled about the major plot
points or those last four words leave
now I'm serious because we're about to
spill it all in three two one over the
course of the four episodes Gilmore
Girls fans discovered that Rory and
Logan still share a romantic connection
despite the fact that they're both
involved in other relationships so et
caught up a star is Alexis Liddell and
Matsu Cree to get the inside scoop on
their scandalous behavior did it
surprise you that Rory was so
comfortable being in a relationship with
Logan while they both were in other
relationships yes it did surprise me and
I think I think it's a little
uncomfortable for her even though she's
kind of I think putting on a brave face
that she's fine with it I think she's
actually not that emotionally connected
to it I think she's kind of going
through the motions at this point where
we pick up with them I think they were
both in the same place at the same time
you know Rory and and Logan if you've
always had a love for each other that
has gone back and forth they've never
really wanted to say goodbye and they're
they're both in the same place at the
same time in this particular story so
it's a mutual relationship that they're
carrying on would you say that Logan is
the Christopher to Rory's Lorelai I
never really looked at it like that I
always looked at Logan as somebody who
was always trying to push Rory to be the
best that she could possibly be in her
personal and professional life so I
never looked at that I think that maybe
Amy and Dan looked at it that way but
that's not the way that I approach the
character
[Music]
you